President Trump has officially signed a
declaration of disaster for Puerto Rico
in a tweet the islands governor thanked
the president for his commitment to
helping Puerto Rico as it continues to
recover from hundreds of earthquakes and
aftershocks so this comes just one day
after the Trump administration released
more than eight billion dollars in
heavily restricted aid for hurricanes
Maria
and Irma you remember that happened a
few years ago that's right filmmaker and
writer Andrew Padilla is here with more
good to see you so the president is
restricting aid to Puerto Rico for
Hurricane Maria and one of those
restrictions is on spending money on the
power grid why is the power grid so
essential in this particular instance
well a lot of the people that lost power
in this recent series of earthquakes
over a thousand and to some odd weeks
they also lost it during Maria right and
so the grid has been unstable since
before Maria so that's what makes this
restriction even crazier do we know what
the reasoning is behind this restriction
because I remember you know at the time
of the hurricanes that was one of the
top conversations that the power grid
already wasn't the best and so would it
be able to sustain not one hit but two
hits and you know it wasn't able to
sustain it what's the rete that you
would think of that would be a primary
place to put the eight the power grid
goes down in light rain it's very clear
that Trump does not care about what doe
Rico the estimated damages and and the
need to recover after Hurricane Maria
the Puerto Rican government told
Congress was somewhere around 130 39
billion so eight billions to drop in the
bucket yeah and it was illegally holding
this right like so this is this is where
we're at and now in this recent moment
with the earthquake it's a little I mean
Maria was scary this is scary in its own
way there are so many people that have
been displaced economically displaced
from the island this 8 billion is a drop
in the bucket you have people leaving
every day the UN says Puerto Rico's
population is going to be 2 million by
the end of this century we lost 500,000
before Maria we are in a population
crisis and so by denying these funds
it's a clear message that they want the
island to depopulate there's really no
other answer because the United States
has the power and the money to support
us you also tweeted that the collapse of
investor
on the island is not a result of bad
luck but as a result of colonialism
explain that well the United States
right now is dealing with Puerto Rico in
a different way than other state that's
not that other states have had wonderful
disaster recoveries the Puerto Rico's
government before these disasters had a
fiscal Control Board that was
controlling its finances right
Democratic control of budgets have been
usurped in Puerto Rico that's part of
the reason the power grid is the way it
is why the waters poisoned and if you
look what happened what's happening in
Puerto Rico it's actually happening in
other places in the US look at Flint
right if you look at Flint Michigan why
did they deal with the poisoning of
their water there's a fiscal manager
that was changing their water sources
right to save money so some of these
affect US states some of this affects us
States but colonialism we have been
suffering under u.s. rule since 1890 in
1898 right Puerto Rico cannot determine
its own fate it now cannot control its
own economy and the u.s. doesn't want to
help with the funds to rebuild so where
does that leave us
so should put a Rico become a state or
would you like to see it independent I
want what are you going to have the
right to determine its own future and
the support to rebuild and and
accomplish that and that's something
that while the US government isn't doing
thankfully people throughout this city
throughout this country throughout the
Diaspora are doing what they can to try
and help with their legal rebuild we
just had a fund raiser in East Harlem
yesterday we're close to 10,000 raised
and that's supporting being on a sort of
a TIA yesterday that's why I'm like a
little tired we we had a wonderful night
last night big on solidago right they go
to daño de bas para la mujer
two organizations that are helping
recover in the south so while the US
government isn't supplying that aid the
diaspora all of us are getting together
to try and fill those gaps it's just a
shame that we have to keep doing that
and so how do you have faith in the
government then I mean we all watch sort
of post hurricanes that the governor's
crisis were - no one wanted the job you
remember that right what are we going
and certainly you know the president
waiting years to distribute aid for the
Hurricanes that cannot build the puerto
ricans faith in their government federal
government and local government
no one import three classes I mean very
few people have faith in the Puerto
Rican government very few
faith in the US government that's why
you know who's there first it's us we
keep each other safe it's up to
individuals who care the US government
doesn't but individual US citizens do
and Puerto Ricans throughout the country
you know have been stepping up and now
Puerto Ricans have been stepping up it's
up to us to do it Trump obviously
doesn't care we're beyond that so what
are we doing to step up and there's a
couple good fundraisers I want people to
know about tonight the New York State
Nurses Association is going to be at 131
West 33rd Street second floor auditorium
they're doing a medical brigades guava
and then I'm Cole co-hosting a
fundraiser at beer wax on the 28th which
will be supporting but he got us sorted
out yet they which again is doing really
good relief we're getting medical
supplies out brigades and trying to
think more sustainably about how we move
forward which is something again sadly
the US government isn't thinking through
it's good that you point out these
fundraisers that are happening because
there is such a lack of you know people
will need to donate to our fellow
Americans because they're in dire
straits and the fact that these we need
to donate that we need to donate to them
because they're humans right not because
they're Americans our citizenship has
nothing to do with this we need to
support Puerto Ricans because they're
humans in crisis because we are being
forced from our island and I'm sorry I
don't mean to cut you off but that's
always the narrative we hear this all
the time oh we have to support them
because they're Americans too and that's
a narrative you've heard especially from
Democrats and that needs to get out it
needs to get oh there's a lot of people
in the earth who need just as much help
and there's a lot of people in this
country to help our fellow citizens as I
think probably what most people are
thinking of although you're right there
yeah we could solve world hunger need
educating - about - no we are so to see
exactly which is the wild you know it
goes back to colonialism a lot of it is
invisibility it's people finding out
that we existed after Hurricane Maria
and remembering oh I guess they still
need help after this crisis meanwhile
we've been going through I think you're
right to point out the colonialism sort
of the history I think if people read
the history of Puerto Rico they would
see why people Rico is where it is right
now
and it's not because Puerto Ricans act
like can't get it together exact there's
a long history there and that's and
going to the insular cases that's
exactly it we are property up but we're
not part of the US and that is at the
root that colonial relationship is at
the root of the inequity when it comes
to funding in normal times or in crisis
Andrew Padilla Padilla thank you very
much thank you for having me or for
supporting absolutely